the thing that makes you the doofy is
that it's his own community that he's
looking at it that they're dealing with
this problem yeah actively like you look
like an ass that's like yo man I support
you Ryan you know I'm helping you out
yeah and then you're like talking
against it and then at home I'm jacking
off to his right and beating and beating
it
[Music]
all right for uh everybody out here this
article is actually submitted by one of
our loyal patrons Chad Ventures oh Chad
Ventures shout out Chad Shadow chat
Adventures
oh tight oh that's Chad crypto corner
right here right there okay
so uh you know if you want to get in
there help submit some articles
this is it here we go popular female
twitch streamers are targeted in deep
fake pornography scandals dude that's uh
this is a crazy one all right so what do
they do grab the faces of them so
there's this twitch streamer his name is
Brandon atriak Ewing right triac he
issued a tearful apology during his live
stream after he accidentally revealed
that he had deep fake pornography of
popular female twitch streamers open on
his computer how did he accidentally
reveal that because he was screen
sharing and then you know like when you
Cascade and you can see little Windows
oh and just people look crazy and
they'll look at every little oh yeah so
he was jacking off game and like see
every freaking detail so uh yeah the
video of his apology in which he claims
have clicked on ADD or clicked an ad on
PornHub because he was curious quickly
gained traction online he's like crying
when he dude that's a terrible watch
this video it's pretty wild he's jacking
off to his colleagues pretty much this
guy's like I'm sorry for beating this
beating it up
he had his wife's in the background like
oh my God our life is over I'm like I
can't believe my marriage is over he's
beating it and beating it away it's
really like funny the juxtaposition's
like gold man so wait his excuse was it
was it was a pop-up well his excuse was
that he got tempted and wanted to look
into it and went down a rabbit hole and
and it was good yeah so he was like oh
if you guys only saw it Oh you would
[__] be not be able to resist like me
so here's the thing except I was trying
to look for big wet asses
and then I got this deep fake video we
[__] Pokeman in it and I feel like
[__] and I started I was already hard
really
that's amazing I'm paraphrased it's
basically it is bad though because like
um the site that he was actually
visiting works like only fans so it
requires people to pay a subscription to
view oh so it's not like uh just
streaming like a confirmed like logged
in members yes and the particular
content creators page he was on was
centered entire early around making deep
fakes of famous twitch streamers so it's
like the niche of that he's like he's
like caught in the media's part of this
several of whom are his real life
friends besides wow it being extremely
embarrassing
what's the like I guess ethical wrong or
moral here's the actually I think
because why is it why is it balling an
apology video because Twitter users in
their misguided attempt to draw
attention to the controversy shared
screenshots of the original stream which
signal boosted the porn site and its
contents making matters worse for the
affected women who learned that they
were on the Deep fake site only because
of Ewing slip up so it's basically one
of those like he's the the last drop in
the bucket that is the Catalyst for all
these people finding out that they're
even being used for deep fake
pornography it's not just that he was
watching it it's like people are
learning that they're a part of this
it's a type of porn oh because deep deep
fake stuff like the chicks have they're
not consenting to it right like all of
our chicks have deep fakes right so like
and we all beat off to them and we all I
was hammering it to her well when we
found out we found out all of our chicks
had deep fakes I think like 2017 I was
like that seems like a very internet
thing yeah you actually really your
chicks actually have defects we all
found out we have a fairly toxic uh fan
base
but we're like but we're like oh that
seems like a very internet thing oh JK
it touches on an existing like issue
that's happening because there's
probably photos of me photoshop with the
big dick in my mouth or whatever right
yeah if anybody has that clip please
send it to us the problem is that for a
lot of female streamers that are not
selling sexual content they've spent a
lot of their own personal money taking
these down so the fact that he's
partaking in that and part of the same
community of people who are actively
spending money to help alleviate the
problem and those are his friends some
of them are his friends or friends
because it's like it's actually a big
problem for that scene because a lot of
these female streamers do not do only
fans they don't do any of that stuff
yeah so they're just like on this
ongoing battle with it the Deep fake
Creator in question has removed all
content from their page and issued an
apology
wow but they can conf uh yeah it
basically Double Down The Creator claims
they stopped making videos and deleted
them if a particular streamer ever dmed
them about it they also wrote that
seeing the impact of Ewing stream was
eye-opening which makes me want to put
you know like basically they say you
only find an issue with uh grafting
famous streamers faces on to lewd bodies
after Twitter comes after you you know
what I mean yeah because like if you're
identified then of course you're gonna
apologize and I'm also like how much did
you make on this content [__] you
should [__] give a cut that's
interesting that that's one that's an
interesting choice to get in the mail
the twitch streamers like you know what
leave my defects there if you give me 50
guys so how many like Angelina Jolie
[__] deep fakes are there and like
all these celebrities they got [__]
defects all over the place well there
don't need to be also because she's been
nude and [__] too so it's a little
different right the these female
streamers are like never put themselves
out there sexually at all I think it's a
copyright violation
took my likeness without you [__]
like I didn't agree to this likeness
[__] is that the like I guess legal or
ethical moral line there's a huge
ethical line that's been crossed I think
I think the ethical line yeah uh is more
crossing the legal line I think the
legal line is still debated yeah because
deep deep fakes are so new there's
probably no actual like legislation yeah
like how much of it falls under parity
or whatever yeah but ethically I think
it's just using someone's likeness
because you could like physically draw a
naked version of somebody it's like yeah
but then you might be able to argue that
it creates like trauma for the person
that you're like stealing they're like
oh yeah because it's so real there's
that legal realm to it right the
defamation like you know what I mean
because if it ruins your brand if that's
not like your brand to be it's so hard
for me to grasp though because it's like
the minute you step foot into the
internet I feel like that's the gamer
playing that's the game you know like
Michael Jordan crying face I don't think
he wants to be known as the crime he
does but if you step foot into it it's
like anything you've ever done could be
turned into any other thing and you have
no control like that's that's the that's
what sucks about the internet but that's
also what's beautiful about it what if I
create it just just to push back here a
little bit yeah yeah exploratively I
like this one yeah
um barquan gloryhole.com
and it's just all Photoshop deep fake
[__] are you sucking every single
project
I honestly and I'm monetizing it I
honestly wouldn't even be surprised so I
also wouldn't be offended because I
think we saw but what if he's like
making millions off I wouldn't care
because it's the internet so but you
wouldn't care but with geocare would
your mom care is so special I think I
have I'm the one with the rights you
know so I don't care if my mom cares
enough what if it's taika could be just
the internet what if you had a daughter
and it's what do you say the daughter
and it's her
what if you already have a lawyer on
retainer that's like hey I can stop this
would you say no it's the internet well
I would admit though that I am fighting
almost a natural disaster yeah you know
like I can put a fence up here but I
live next to a place that's prone to
tsunamis that's something I'm I
committed to living here so I can put as
much money as I want but I have to
understand if I don't want to get wet
maybe I should be Inland a little bit
more what about how Joe got that [__]
up deep fake Reddit removed recently
finally
um were you are you supportive of that
are you like I don't go no I was like
that's dope I mean obviously it's dope
but I'm like I I think I think it's
almost like reposted it's like Isis
leaders right you take this one out
there's gonna be another one there's
gonna be another one there's gonna be
another one so to me I'm like it's a
it's a never
ending battle this is how I view it and
so like because we also saw the internet
come to be so I think my first thing
that I ever witnessed was like uh Asian
sleeping in the library
you guys remember that there's like a
really popular site I would say probably
two thousand I don't know five six seven
and it's just pictures of Asian sleeping
libraries so the minute I saw that it's
just like Asians like this like this and
sleeping bags and that's like one of the
most viral things ever right so I'm like
oh this is a machine zero people have
control over
so when as we started to commit more
towards JK I just realized if you put
anything out there it's Unstoppable you
can you can unless you can track IP or
whatever jpeg like people can modify do
and just to be clear you're not saying I
support I'm not saying I support it
you're saying it's pointless to fight it
I'm trying to view the accuracy of the
situation I think what people are trying
to create is like um they want to be
able to use this space safely and to Reg
to have it regulated and have some
control over
um you know maybe their likeness or like
there's all this new technology it's
like so like if if I was jacking off on
the street and someone took a picture of
that and spread it online that's my
fault I was jacking off on the street
right but in this case like they're
putting my face on someone who jacked
off on the street and then the
technology is so good it could it could
be believable or like how about like
Pamela Anderson and Tommy right yeah I
think it's just different for guys like
because because Tommy Lee had his dick
out there and everyone's like let's go
Tommy [__] slaying it with that big
old beast and but then Pamela had to
deal with like she's like being [__]
on camera and all this stuff and like
having an intimate moment with her
husband by the way because there's a
double standard where women are [__]
and now she's a [__] forever and then
and if these girls deep fakes like leak
and then they're like people don't know
if it's not real or whatever and then
what ends up happening is like it can
technically ruin their career and
pokeman's not out there saying like hey
everyone viewed me sexually so like but
then now there's this video and then
she'll that that is what gets talked
about right and so that's kind of what
happened with Pamela Anderson and then
it becomes merged with your brand yeah
so for me I I think my emotional problem
with that [__] sucks because that's
not something that she ever wanted and
that's it sucks to have your brand and
your likeness tied to something like
that but also I think the way I see it
is
this is also the internet not saying
it's okay or I support it but it's I'm
trying to view it as realistically as
possible like if you put out you could
be anybody you could be in sync you put
out a song into the internet you better
believe there's gonna be at least 300
other parodies of the same song that
they covered and it's about content that
you don't want I just think everyone
gets that like I think everyone gets it
it's pointless to fight it but I think
the more people making it uncomfortable
for people to do something like this
well yeah so it's basically like this
like yeah like like let's say songs
would be
um stolen or whatever right but then the
conversation still needs to be had so
then it can be regulated and other fixed
yeah so like now we have Spotify and
whatever and then people are like well
you know what there's a happy medium
where we get music for free but then the
artists get paid versus like only
California and Virginia actually have
explicit loss surrounding D fake
pornography so there is actual
regulation and law in a way that like
even though you can't stop it you can
sue for it in California and Virginia oh
so like if it does actually happen to to
you there's like like ab602 allows
California residents to sue if their
image is used for sexually explicit
content but the idea that it's not like
federal or that it doesn't happen in all
states or something like that I think
maybe is also a little bit of like where
this conversation I just think it's also
just much different for men right
because we we you know
um when we
are jerking off on the Internet or
something like that people kind of
already expect that you're a dude and
you guys are gross and you guys are you
know what I mean like with women it's
like oh she's a [__] and all this
[__] and then guys are already
looking at them on the street and like
on the internet as pieces of meat that
they can [__] and then now they have a
visual aid for that I just think it's
just a different thing for us that's
true because if I get caught naked like
it's not a big [__] deal so if for us
decision go I don't know if I get caught
jerking off I'm kind of like that's kind
of awesome it's just not the same right
yeah it also depends on your previous
reputation like if you're Richard Gere
getting caught jacking off it's
different than Tommy Lee yeah yeah
[__] Rockstar that's your thing
that's true but if you're if you're just
like a Tom Hanks
yeah devastating
and you have nothing to do with sex
you're just trying to [__] clean
people's houses there's probably
it's getting easier to take things down
like dmcas are easier to issue nowadays
than ever before you have women who have
only fans and they're able to take down
their content when it's posted free a
lot of the time awesome so there's
there's more success in fighting these
things now than there ever was yeah when
you think about the Pam Pam Anderson sex
tape thing right it's like she gets
roasted for that still like like to this
day like comedians do bits about that
because it's it's part of our national
Consciousness so you do bits about what
everyone knows right so like Pamela
Anderson's like at a Comedy Central
roast and they're all half of the
materials about a sex tape that got
leaked that you made with your husband
now that's your first layer of like and
it's your identity it's built into the
fabric of your of your person her kids
recently spoke out about that as well
because now there's the movie yeah
that's why I keep mentioning it because
it's really and they're saying that
during the time uh no it's like a
documentary yeah I think it's on Netflix
but then they were talking about how
during that time that the sex tape was
released she had an option to either
like own it it and actually release it
or sell for something and make money and
she didn't want it out but it got out
and then now they said that she was like
during the time of that making its
rounds that she was heavily like not
financially stable like she was very she
was kind of wow and during that time
it's not like a Paris Hilton move too
like she basically it could have exactly
it ruined her career there really wasn't
any good that came from that for her
personally no way how could it because
her career just went down from that
point on and that's why the kids kind of
don't like the the fact that more
stuff's being made like the new series
or whatever that's coming out the dock
because they're like it's just gonna
make it worse in terms of her Legacy
that is that is the Legacy I would love
for somebody to ask Seth Rogen about
that because like you know he's
like he's out there like he's one of the
producers that I guess yeah he produced
it yeah he produced it I was just
curious to hear what his angle is on
that like what he thinks about wait he
produced the topic thing really yeah
yeah interesting because he's in it
who's in it too yeah yeah really you
know what's crazy with uh all the like
algorithms and Bots and stuff that can
like
catch that you're using a song or
whatever or even saying certain words
it's crazy that they can't have
something that automatically takes deep
fakes down it's so hard though because
like even the way that they get made
think about the way they get made like
it's the way that deep fakes are made I
was watching those guys um the special
effects dudes and they were making just
deep fakes with um celebrity faces like
in superhero movies and [__] and it's
Advanced [__] yeah like that they have
to do to perform so like the the idea
that an algorithm is smart enough to
find that I don't think that we're there
yet yeah like the Tom Cruise
a couple years ago Reddit and PornHub
banned deep fake porn so there there is
some Focus there's some progress that's
why I think like when when uh the
technology precedes the legislation your
best bet is social justice in a way
where you just have to ostracize people
that like this [__] yeah and therefore
that's why the dude's crying he's not
crying he's just crying because he got
caught doing some [__] that he knows
everyone will hate him for yeah and
that's what I mean that's why I get the
Folly of it because I agree like it is I
once something's out it's out and there
it's impossible to delete everything but
I think steering the conversation more
towards like how that's wrong and [__]
up yeah that's kind of how that's why
he's weeping yeah yeah making him like
the uh what's the word
um
martyr not martyr
exactly exactly yeah
because I I think I'm on the same page
when it comes to the initial approach of
the situation it's like
um it's like to be expected that when
you do want to become a social media
star or anything right like it comes
with the territory of you can't control
your likeness in a lot of ways after
you're famous I understand that point so
you're like psychologically preparing
for the craziest [__] to go down which
is fine right but then I think people
are more focused on the aftermath of how
do we as a society deal with these
situations and I think that's where the
conversation rather than like just being
upset about it but then when you I think
when you say that in the beginning it
sounds like a passive approach of these
things yeah yeah exactly are so big that
like you can't do anything exactly but
then I think what people are trying to
do is like is like shun it and go that's
wrong long and something should be done
about it yes because nothing is being
done about it like you said two states
have it illegal right now yeah and Tech
moves way faster than law yeah and well
and you know just because it's illegal
doesn't mean it's not all being done
constantly right now obviously it is so
that's the thing about it to me too plus
you know it's personal because obviously
we like like whenever you yes when you
put yourself out there there is a
potential that people will do whatever
they want with your likeness but that
doesn't make it okay yeah and and
there's this [__] too where we you
know say you view a woman in a movie or
whatever and there's this thing well
they're out there so we deserve to like
see what she would look like naked or
whatever it is you can put herself in
the public so we can do all this
[__] with our brains to justify it
but we know what's wrong but they need
to be old school and just spank bank it
in their mind and imagine it exactly see
that's that's you're creating this what
I'm trying to say you're doing you're
deep freaking in your head dude
you should be like old school with it
that's the Boomer style but it's hotter
anyway as a streamer isn't that like the
biggest [__] oofy doofies you could
do is like have porn up on your [__]
screen that you're it's an oofie I don't
know if it's a doofy though the thing
that makes you the doofy is that it's
his own community that he's looking at
it they're dealing with this problem
actively like you look like an ass
that's like yo man I support you Ryan
you know it's helping you out yeah and
then you're like talking against it and
then at home I'm jacking off to his [__]
right yeah beating and beating it the
funniest thing to me then I don't
believe that anybody who gets caught
because they like something immediately
stop like it yeah bro stop it
you you don't think it's just a new you
think it's a doofy too you think it's
over he crying because he got caught no
I think I think for I don't think it's
over for him yeah he's a martyr he's a
martyr I think it's I think it's over
for his in how his peers see him and
that's a big problem if you're part of
like a a whole Community people that's
moving upward together now they're Gonna
Leave You in the dust but no one's gonna
like this guy because it's the same it's
the same if you like you're like oh stop
Asian hate and then on the back you have
all this like Asian violence
that's a doofy though there's all these
guys getting all these Asians Well yeah
if it's racial you're not coming back
but I think there's a good chance
there's a lot of people that already
follow him that also like what he likes
and don't find a problem with that yeah
because they also like jacking off to
the but they have a problem with being
caught for liking 100 just like he does
you know you just didn't want to get
caught liking that [__] no on and I'm
sure they were threatening his like
ability to make money too right like
people are trying to cancel well in that
Community it's like you're paying you
know what I mean guys like this are
making money meanwhile people that he's
watching it's like you're also in the
community what you're paying they're
making money but they're using their
money to [__] spend on taking down
deep fakes yeah you know what I mean so
it's almost whereas this guy's
perpetuating where that currency goes
and him crying apologizing about it's
kind of lame but like when Louis CK got
caught free [__] how he was like it's
embarrassing and now everyone knows my
thing that I like but he didn't say oh I
don't like it now yeah yeah it's like
dude he [__] is still owning up to
the fact that it's weird and gross but
it's embarrassing everybody knows I was
like I like lock on a door and I like
stroking it off and I like knowing she
doesn't want to see that
that's what I own it